as russia's war machine rages across
ukraine the verbal offensive coming from
moscow is no less powerful
president putin issued a clear warning
to western powers saying any attempt to
create a no-fly zone over ukraine would
be considered a direct military
involvement in the conflict against
russia
now we are hearing that no-fly zone must
be established over the territory of
ukraine
it is impossible to do so over the
territory of ukraine itself it is
possible only from the territory of some
neighboring countries but any move in
this direction will be viewed by us as a
participation in the armed conflict
putin made it clear he wants ukraine to
have a neutral status in the power
balance between nato and russia
this he says requires a demilitarized
ukraine because its western backers are
intending to supply it with nuclear
weapons if not stopped they will arm
those systems and from that second on
from that very second russia's fate will
be very different because then our
strategic enemy won't even need
intercontinental ballistic missiles they
will have us at gunpoint right here how
can we overlook that
putin said everything is going according
to plan in ukraine and his army will
achieve all of its objectives his
foreign minister sergey lavrov had some
harsh words for the ukrainian president
if zelensky's so unhappy with nato not
interfering then that means he's hoping
to resolve this conflict by involving
nato it means he's not hearing
statements from european capitals saying
they won't get involved it means he
wants to provoke a conflict between nato
and russia
perhaps the most challenging issue for
russia right now is the economic
measures the west is imposing in this
regard president putin says western
sanctions are akin to a declaration of
war on his country foreign minister
lavrov has warned of consequences and
singled out the uk in particular he says
moscow's response to the sanctions will
without doubt hurt british interests in
russia because in his words the uk has
chosen to move towards a direct
confrontation with his country muhammad
al jazeera